you are now dr. Dennis Jerry answer a
classified just tell you something okay
I was a horrible student in high school
admittedly all I did was go to school to
torture nuns for 12 years and they
deserved it they had coming yeah and to
smoke and to meet girls and a little bit
of drinking and and I also drank the
holy wine one time at the church which
was awesome I don't do that yeah yeah do
that we all had the holy one yeah it was
pretty had to have the holy one I hint
you don't walk on water anyways but I
did when I went to Emerson College I did
do very well cuz I studied acting and
writing and I liked it and after I
graduated and became famous when you're
a famous guy they will give you a
doctorate you go and you make a speech
and and I thought you went to medical
school no yes swear to God I thought you
took time off 59 you Reilly hard and
that you were now an icer yeah and no I
taught I went that medical school taught
doctors how to smoke yeah no so so I
went and I and I gave the shortest
graduation speech I think in the history
of graduation speeches and I got a
standing ovation
what was it that's amazing okay my wife
said to me do not write a long
complicated speech they don't want to
hear it remember when you graduated when
I graduated from Emerson College Michael
Dukakis spoke for an hour and 15 minutes
right and if you know who Michael
Dukakis is you don't want to even be in
a room with him when he's quiet
yeah hours 15 right right so I went up
and I said thank you for this and let's
go party yeah got a standing ovation
what that's all you did all I did and
you didn't get sued by like the parent I
think the kids loved me I know the kids
would love it yeah I know you are you a
doctor
I don't think so
but you did a [ __ ] think I have you had a
famous speech at Harvard your alma mater
I gave one at Harvard they're not gonna
give me anything those why'd you do the
speech that why they invited me and I
thought I got to go back and give one
for that but then I did one at Dartmouth
I think maybe are you guys from
Dartmouth that looks um catches back it
up for a second
anyone watching at home thinks that's a
total setup wait that looks like the
most [ __ ] set up like very didn't
you give a speech yes well now I look
like a jerk now we're you were you kids
at his graduation speech at Dartmouth
know that was a long time ago yeah
everyone who was that at mine they all
died of old age now listen the year was
1932
I saw your Harvard speech because it was
it made the news and I went online I saw
it was like 45 minutes long it was
really long wait a minute wait a minute
first of all that's a lie no maybe if
you count all the laughs to your credit
you did a real speech about like chasing
your dreams and changing the world did
know I didn't look it up go look it up
this is okay are you telling me even the
only long speech that say go chase your
dreams I thought then you have me
confused yeah you confused with somebody
like Danner I didn't never gave that
speech awesome no no I I did not give a
speech like that but you are now a
doctor yes I am are you gonna walk
around and be called dr. Leary oh I only
do it when I write a book that's my
thing now so when I write a book I think
it's funny that I call myself dr. Denis
Larry when I write a book I think I
sound more important yeah and it I think
it gives more import to what I write
yeah so more important or more sad word
of advice if you're on a plane and they
say is there a doctor
[Applause]
you